>>> THE VACCINE MANDATE WENT
INTO EFFECT FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA TODAY AND
IT APPEARS TO HAVE COMPELLED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF VACCINE
EMPLOYEES TO GET VACCINATED IN
RECENT WEEKS.
MORE THAN A DOZEN OF THE STATE'S
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS SHOW THERE WERE
VACCINATIONS THIS WEEK OF 90% OR
HIGHER, BUT THAT LEAVES 15%
WITHOUT GETTING VACCINATED.
WHY ARE SOME SO RELUCTANT TO GET
VACCINATED?
DR. SANJAY GUPTA SPOKE TO ONE
NURSE WHO REFUSES TO GET
VACCINATED.
THIS WAS IN CHICAGO?
WERE YOU SURPRISED ABOUT WHAT
SHE TOLD YOU?
>> I FEEL SO FAR AT THIS POINT
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT I KNOW
ABOUT THE VACCINE, IF I HAVE
ENOUGH TIME WITH SOMEBODY, I CAN
CONVINCE THEM.
I CAN ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS AND
I CAN CONVINCE THEM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO A
HEALTH CARE WORKER, SOMEONE WHO
LIVES IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
SURROUNDED BY GOOD INFORMATION
AND GOOD KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THIS.
WHAT I LEARNED TALKING TO HER IS
THERE IS A LOT GOING ON HERE.
LISTEN TO PART OF THE
CONVERSATION.
>> IT SHOULDN'T BE A CHOICE
BETWEEN A PERSONAL HEALTH CARE
DECISION AND, YOU KNOW, THE JOB
THAT WE LOVE.
>> YOU WOULD LOSE YOUR JOB OVER
THIS.
>> OBVIOUSLY, IT'S
HEARTBREAKING.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A GRIEVING
PROCESS, TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
>> Reporter: ANDRA IS ONE OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT COULD
GET VACCINATED BUT SHE WON'T.
SHE'S BEEN A HEALTH CARE WORKER
FOR 12 YEARS.
>> EVER SINCE THIS MANDATE CAME
OUT, MANY ARE LEAVING HEALTH
CARE IN THIS SPECIFIC HOSPITAL.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING NURSING
DEPARTMENT, WE'RE TALKING THE
EAs, WHICH IS THE HOUSEKEEPING
DEPARTMENT, DIETARY, LAUNDRY,
RESPIRATORY THERAPY DEPARTMENT.
>> Reporter: ABOUT 85% OF THE
STAFF HAVE BEEN VACCINATED, BUT
A SMALL GROUP HAS INSTEAD STAGED
PROTESTS AT THE HOSPITAL,
INCLUDING ANDREA HERSELF.
ONE OF HER SPECIFIC CONCERNS?
BLOOD CLOTS.
>> IF YOU WERE MY PATIENT.
LET'S SAY WE WERE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IN A PATIENT ROOM
INSTEAD, I WOULD SAY, LOOK, I
HEAR YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
CLOTTING, BUT IF YOU HAVE A
CLOTTING DISORDER, YOU SHOULD
GET THE VACCINE BECAUSE YOU
WOULD BE AT INCREASED CLOTTING
IF YOU GOT THE DISEASE.
>> YOU KNOW VERY WELL WITH THIS
PANDEMIC, THIS VACCINE, THIS
VIRUS, THE SCIENCE IS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT SCIENCE IS
CHANGING AS WE FIND OUT MORE
THINGS.
>> BUT I THINK WITH THE VACCINE,
I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE CLOSE TO 6
BILLION SHOTS THAT HAVE NOW BEEN
ADMINISTERED AROUND THE WORLD
AND YOU HAVE DATA, TRIAL DATA
FROM LAST YEAR, THAT SHOWS THE
SAFETY AND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE VACCINES AND THEN REAL
WORLD DATA OVER THE LAST NINE
MONTHS, IT REALLY DOES MAKE A
STRONG CASE.
>> I'M NOT ANTI-VACCINE, I'M NOT
ANTI-COVID VACCINE, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, INFORMED CONSENT
IS WHAT WE ALL HONOR IN NURSING.
I'VE STOOD UP FOR A LOT OF MY
PATIENTS OVER THE YEARS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUSHED INTO SOMETHING,
AND IT'S THEIR BODY, IT'S A
CHOICE THAT THEY SHOULD MAKE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THAT I SHOULD
MAKE FOR MYSELF.
>> AS A DOCTOR, I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH INFORMED CONSENT,
BUT WITH ALL YOUR KNOWLEDGE AS A
NURSE, DON'T YOU DRAW A LINE
WHEN IT COMES TO A CONTAGIOUS
DISEASE?
THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE WORKING IN
A HOSPITAL WHERE THERE ARE SICK
AND VULNERABLE PEOPLE, AND YOU
COULD POTENTIALLY BE THE CARRIER
OF A VIRUS AND NOT KNOW IT
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE ANY
SYMPTOMS --
>> I'VE HAD MULTIPLE COWORKERS
TEST POSITIVE FOR COVID IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS THAT ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
I THINK A SAFER OPTION WOULD BE
REGULAR TESTING FOR ALL OF US,
VACCINATED AND UNVACCINATED
ALIKE.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THIS OBVIATES
TESTING OR WEARING PPE AND ALL
THOSE THINGS.
YOU WOULDN'T SAY I'M NOT WEARING
A SEAT BELT BECAUSE I HAVE AN
AIRBAG.
OF COURSE YOU WOULD WEAR A SEAT
BELT.
I KNOW A GUY WHO WORE A SEAT
BELT AND STILL DIED, THEREFORE
THEY DON'T WORK.
YOU AS A NURSE ARE MOST EQUIPPED
TO UNDERSTAND AND KNOW AND LEARN
AND PREACH, QUITE FRANKLY,
RATHER THAN SELLING THIS DOUBT.
IT WORRIES ME.
IT WORRIES ME ABOUT WHERE WE GO
NOW, AND IT WORRIES ME ABOUT
WHERE WE MIGHT GO IF THERE IS
ANOTHER PANDEMIC.
I HAVE TO LEAVE IT WITH JUST
SAYING, I THINK YOU SHOULD GET
VACCINATED.
WILL YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
>> WILL I THINK ABOUT GETTING
VACCINATED?
>> YEAH.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'VE PUT A LOT OF
THOUGHT INTO THIS ALREADY.
AS FAR AS RIGHT NOW, I HAVE NO
PLANS TO GET VACCINATED, BUT I'M
WILLING TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION
OPEN WITH -- STILL LISTENING TO
OTHERS' POINT OF VIEW.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WOULD
CONVINCE YOU TO GET VACCINATED?
>> NOT AT THIS POINT.
I GUESS NEVER SAY NEVER.
>> IT'S FASCINATING.
JUST FACTUALLY SPEAKING, FIRST
OF ALL, I DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND
WHAT HER ARGUMENT IS TO NOT GET
VACCINATED.
YOU MENTIONED THE BLOOD CLOT
THING, WHICH DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
BUT ALSO WHEN YOU ASK HER A VERY
RATIONAL QUESTION OF, WELL,
YOU'RE AROUND PEOPLE WHO COULD
BE INFECTED IF YOU'RE POSITIVE
AND DON'T KNOW IT, SHE SAID,
WELL, THAT'S WHY I THINK REGULAR
TESTING IS FAR SAFER.
BUT AS YOU SAID, YOU CAN BE
VACCINATED AND STILL GET REGULAR
TESTING, JUST, AS SHE SAID,
PEOPLE THAT GET VACCINATED HAVE
IT.
BUT EVEN IF SHE GOT COVID, IF
SHE'S VACCINATED, SHE IS LESS
LIKELY TO TRANSMIT IT TO
SOMEBODY ELSE AND THE COVID SHE
HAS IS LESS LIKELY TO HARM AND
KILL HER.
>> NO QUESTION, SHE'S LESS
LIKELY TO GET INFECTED, SHE'S
LESS LIKELY TO TRANSMIT IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE, AND ONE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY PRECLUDE THE OTHER.
YOU COULD DO BOTH.
I THINK SHE'S A RATIONAL PERSON,
YOU KNOW, THE CONVERSATION WAS A
LONG ONE, IT WAS 30 MINUTES
LONG.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AT HER HOSPITAL AND MOST
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
VACCINATED.
IN SOME PLACES 99%.
SO THIS IS A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
BUT WHAT WAS SO INTERESTING IS
THAT ULTIMATELY AFTER REALLY
DANCING AROUND THIS FOR SOME
TIME, I REALLY THOUGHT I WAS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONVINCE
HER.
I FELT LIKE, HOW COULD I NOT BE
ABLE TO CONVINCE THIS PERSON?
IT REALLY CAME DOWN TO THE
MANDATE FOR HER, THAT IT FELT
TOOAUTHORITARIAN, THEY'RE
TELLING HER WHAT TO DO.
>> THAT'S WHAT I GOT OUT OF IT,
BECAUSE SHE KEPT GOI